real weed small grass yeah yeah  hold on hold on you got it backwards if  you got it back backwards backwards you  got it backwards you got it because  backwoods cover up the smell the taste  of disgusting wheat oh really hold on  but okay did you smoke  you could taste it you smoke bammer in a  backwood it'll mask it slightly because  of the tobacco and the thickness you  have you have agreed with me on this  topic many times you see you got any  [ __ ] it's in a backwood anyway you have  said that before so i'll fight him right  i say this right oh i say yo do you have  any any  any cheap weed stop yeah  this guy doesn't have cheap weed who why  would he have cheap weed  it doesn't matter oh [ __ ] cheap weed to  him is like amazing no i don't care i  don't care what you say  i don't care if you smoke backwards i'm  not saying you smoke trash no saying you  can cover trash you could in a back one  it's like a see-through uh  [Music]